but now coming back to this sub circle
right if instead of having two points
that were separate from each other if I
took these two points and grabbed them
and brought them together at the same
point so if they were sitting on top of
each other okay and then if I drew the
same chord secant it wouldn't actually
be a secret anymore would it because
this slide here this new one this is no
longer cutting the circle is it it's not
cutting at all it's just it's just
touching just like just a little bit on
okay we have a word in English that
means like a thing that can be touched I
think you can grab on to it's not like
it's not like a you can grab it we call
such objects tangible right it's like I
can hold on to this thing and that's why
this object here is called a tangent
it's the same word right
it literally means it's just touching so
to turn please seek it into a tangent
we're bringing these two points together
right and we're breathing closer and
closer and closer until they sit on top
of each other okay
now the length of this chord right have
a look at your diagram right the length
of that chord is kind of like H remember
that it's like that little distance
across the bottom a run and we tried to
make that run smaller from 2 to 1 to 1/2
but what if we could make that run
exactly 0 then you would not get the
gradient of the chord you get the
gradient of this object over here the
gradient of the tension here's the way
we're going to consider it we are going
to say instead of this difference
question right we want the gradient of
the tangent
bear with me for a second it starts with
this difference question we're still
calculating the same thing so I'm going
to leave a gap here for me I'm going to
write the difference question here just
like I did before
but what I want to do is introduce some
language and some way of thinking to
take this this run this this length of
this chord business right and make it
smaller and smaller and smaller like if
there were no limit to how small I could
make it and in fact that's exactly what
we call this object we call it a limit
mathematicians lazy so they don't write
the whole word so Lim is an abbreviation
for limit but I'm gonna write this
underneath what I want is for H to get
really tiny I want H to get toward a
length of zero that's what I want now
keep in mind right this is kind of
impossible because then you're dividing
by zero right you're like Oh gross I'm
not meant to be able to do that right
I'm not meant to be able to do that but
what I'm trying to do is imagine what if
I could like physically so I'm gonna
borrow this again physically I cannot
measure a run of zero because if there's
a runner zero there's a rise of zero as
well okay but that's the whole power of
this number one of mathematics we can
imagine things that can't physically
exist and number two of this idea right
it's a fiction that helps us to
understand what's really going on okay
now one last time remember I asked you I
put it's like a rhetorical question what
do you think the equation of this
parabola is okay there are two
intercepts one right here at the origin
and the other one here at x equals four
it's red you have question x squared
minus four X let's see if Jemaine is
right how could we tell if y equals this
accurately represents this graph how
would you work it out what could you do
with if I showed you that instead of the
graph what would you do to it what would
be your instant wrested you can
factorize it's a great idea what's a
common factor
hold on have a look there's just two
things it's just next right X I can take
out of birth so that leaves us with X
minus 4 have a look at these two does
that give us this jemaine's original
equation give us the roots that we want
0 & 4 good there's one last thing right
is that down the bottom meant to be
where it like look how high and tall it
is okay is that gonna make sense if you
put in x equals two x equals two do you
get this x equals two it should be four
minus eight right negative four is that
what I expected
thumbs up it is x squared minus four X
so here's what I want us to do
thanks mrs. Lee's I'm really putting you
to way today I want us to consider
instead of some random f of X okay let's
consider an actual f of X the one that
I've gotten frigerator right x squared
minus 4x let's consider this guy okay oh
by the way I did promise I did promise I
was gonna write this properly this guy
here live it's short for what do we say
was an abbreviation limit thank you
please write that down now before we
forget what it stands for okay all right
so now we have an actual function we can
actually substitute this in it's gonna
be a little bit messy you know I'll show
you this before sometimes things get
worse before they get better but let's
see what happens okay it's greedy near
the tangent I'm gonna need all my space
over here so I'm gonna start right over
here okay firstly and every time I know
it's gonna get a little bit tiresome but
trust me it's important I'm gonna write
this thing the limit thing out the front
right because what I'm interested it is
I don't want these approximations we
tried that approximation of to
approximation of one proximation and a
half I want to be precise so this is
saying don't just have like a little
triangle have an infinitely small one if
this is my f of X okay I see f of X
right there so I'm just gonna write that
all the way over here it's x squared
minus 4x that's the takeaway f of X what
will f of X plus h be what does that
mean like if I told you it f of v right
it means you put in five everywhere you
saw X right but I'm not saying it for
five I'm saying F of this
so everywhere I saw Rex before I'm gonna
put X + H let's do that it's gonna take
a little bit of space okay
so let's see here I've instead of x
squared I'm gonna write X plus h square
ok so that's the first bit squared
because this is square and then in my
function it says take away 4 well it's
going to be for lots of the X plus h
right did I leave enough space
I think I just barely did okay so I know
that looks a bit messy yet stay with it
there is f of X plus h all the extras
got replaced with X plus HS you see how
why we spent so much time on function
notation before right and then this is f
of X you care with that what's a little
Dominator just H thank God that's simple
because the numerator is so messy okay
are you following so far this is the
difference question but I'm thinking
about it in a really really small
triangle okay all right equals again I'm
right in the limit have to write every
single time this thing at the top the
numerator I've got all these X's and HS
flying around I reckon we can work on
this I reckon we can expand this and we
can start to simplify some stuff can you
help me work out what is X plus h or
squared what am I going to do x squared
plus double the product plus a square
very good okay that's the X plus h all
squared they don't take you away what am
i taking away be careful for that minus
sign right the minus sign is going to
distribute the distributive law to all
of the things inside the brackets so I'm
going to get minus 4x and minus 4 H very
good so I know that looks longer messy
but that's everything in the square
brackets okay
all right now we want to expand this as
well be careful for these negatives
so minus x squared are very good so
you've got this double negative
happening so that's y plus 4x and then
I'm done with the numerator and on the
bottom is just H okay that's the
messiest and worse this is like this is
going to get but look at what we've done
have a little careful at this numerator
I can cancel some stuff right someone
tell me one thing I can cancel yeah
okay great x squared and minus x squared
so I can definitely care so that's
someone tell me something else it up
negative 4x and plus 4x anything else I
think we got it okay good so on our next
slide let's collapse this down a little
bit what's always the first thing I'm
writing it's always this limit business
this limit thing right because I'm
considering this tangent all right the x
squared is gone
so my next one is 2x H next term plus h
squared next term minus 4-h and then I
divide with an H but look look because
of what's cancelled on the top this H
here right it's now a common factor all
the way up here through the top so I can
just divide through do you see that so I
can say the limit as H approaches 0 of
I'm just going to divide this thing
through I get 2x plus h minus 4 ok I
just pause on that for a brief moment do
you remember when we wrote this down at
the beginning and for many times right
we were like that's weird how can you
make H equal like becomes euro it can't
become 0 right because then you're going
to divide by 0 that's a bad idea right
and we keep having this problem all the
way through because this H is just stuck
there on the bottom on the numerator and
you can't divide by 0 but now this line
is different what's different about this
line here Japan well yeah the
denominator here if I wrote one would be
divided by 1 no problems right this H
becoming 0 is no problem at all if you
have a look at this object this object
here what will it become if that guy is
0 that 2x will still be there right
because it has nothing to do with it
she's like I don't care what H is this
guy becomes 0 and what about this - 4
what happens to that
it's just- for he doesn't care what H is
either this thing here what we've got
here is actually our gradient of the
tangent okay
now the bell is going I want to show you
one last thing this was the point of
that 2x minus 4 you've got that on your
page right
2x minus 4 there we go okay
2x minus 4 let's think about an x value
here's an x value here write negative 1
if you put negative 1 into 2x minus 4
what would you get if I that's a should
repeat it because I set a lot of things
right I've got this 2x minus 4 this
thing here is the gradient of the
tangent right if I put negative 1 into
this you get negative 6 don't you so at
this spot right here not like as an
average at this exact spot the grading
would be negative 6 which makes it see
how steep it is right
what about at a spot like this at x
equals 0 it'd be negative 4 at that
point not an approximation it's exactly
negative 4 have a look right down here
way way down at the bottom x equals 2
what happens when you put x equals 2
into that guy 0 yeah what does that mean
a grain of zero it's oh it's flat it's
not rising anywhere right that's why
it's going straight across and you can
keep on going right